this is every country in the world part
2 by wendover productions
if you haven't seen part 1 click here to
watch that first
we left off last time in suriname our
98th country
suriname is the only country other than
the netherlands whose sole primary
language is dutch
although there are other countries that
speak a creole version of dutch like
namibia
which speaks africans which is just
close enough to dutch that a dutch and
namibian could hold a conversation
namibia has this long protrusion which
gives them access to the zambezi river
although they miss out by about 300 feet
on bordering zimbabwe which is the
country fairies have to pass through
when making the 600 foot trip from
botswana to zambia
this is likely the shortest ferry in the
world to cross through three countries
to the northeast of zambia is one of the
world's 176 tripoints
triple border crossings this one links
zambia to malawi and tanzania whose
northern border is a very straight line
across lake victoria which creates these
two tiny cut off peninsulas
uganda is a surprisingly progressive
nation with the highest representation
of women in parliament in the world at
63 percent
they also became the first country in
the world to outright ban plastic bags
in 2007.
the solomon islands on the other hand
only has a one woman in their parliament
or two percent representation the
solomon islands is home to the west
georgia
islands which share a name with georgia
which kind of shares a name with
george's plane in jamaica which is one
of two countries in the world whose flag
doesn't share colors with the american
flag as in no red
white or blue the other one is
mauritania but libya used to be on that
list until they changed their flag from
this to this
in 2011. libya is so large that its
northwest point
is closer to luxembourg than to its
southeast point luxembourg has the
second highest per capita income
in the world behind qatar a small but
mighty country that's just a bit larger
than lebanon
who shares a southern border with a
united nations disengagement observer
force zone which is an area essentially
without sovereignty
meant to serve as a buffer between
israeli-controlled syria and syria
one could call it a demilitarized zone
although the most famous dmz is north of
south korea
where if you dig a hole straight down
and through the earth you'd pop up just
off the coast of uruguay
uruguay was a military dictatorship up
until 1985
but thailand still is the only current
one bangkok thailand is the most visited
city in the world
at 16 million yearly visitors which is a
ton
especially compared to vilnius lithuania
which only sees 180 000 visitors per
year
lithuania has a rather straight border
through this lake which leads to two
peninsulas with their tops chopped off
and an internationally divided island
with belarus which has a rather straight
border in this lake which leads to
another peninsula with his top dropped
off
and an internationally divided island
with latvia latvia's independence day is
may the 4th
aka star wars day whose scenes on
tatooine were filmed in tunisia
tunisia's currency is the dinar which is
also the name for the currency in
macedonia
if you look at macedonia on a map it
will almost always have fyrom under its
name which stands for former yugoslav
republic of macedonia when macedonia
became an independent country
they picked this name but greece wasn't
all too happy about it since their
northern region is
also called macedonia so the solution
was to call the country the former
yugoslav republic of macedonia
in all official capacities while
colloquially it's still known as
macedonia
greece is known for having a huge
expatriated population around the world
and the 39th largest greek population in
the world is in oman
in the middle east inside oman is an
ex-slave of the united arab emirates
except this part of oman is actually an
enclave inside the uae
which makes this the only double enclave
in the middle east
the uae is one of 18 countries worldwide
to not have a river
one of which is tonga which actually has
an olympic medal from their super
heavyweight boxer peya wolfgram another
country that has one total medal is
gabon
whose southern border is shared with
congo whose southern border is shared
with this rather large exclave of angola
only because of that exclave angola
borders both congo and the democratic
republic of the congo
these are of course two different
countries although they're both named
for the congo river
the deepest river in the world at more
than 750 feet deep
interestingly despite being both
enormous countries their current
capitals are just on opposite sides of
the congo from each other the drc has
this great clean border with rwanda
which causes no problems at all unlike
this one in austria
jung holz is only connected to the rest
of austria by about 15 feet of territory
and no
roads vienna austria used to be the
capital of the austria-hungarian empire
whose territory included present-day
italy poland germany croatia montenegro
and serbia all of which we've already
talked about and bosnia and herzegovina
the czech republic hungary romania
slovakia and ukraine
ukraine has this southern section which
isn't part of russia yet although it's
only connected to the rest of ukraine by
two roads
one of which rather inconveniently
passes through moldova for only about
three miles
moldova is rated the third least
touristy country in the world since only
one tourist visits each year for every
323 citizens
although bangladesh is the number one
least touristy country since for each
yearly tourist visit
there are 1 273 bangladeshi citizens
bahrain on the other hand receives 7.7
tourist visits per citizen per year
and also has an internationally divided
island but this one was actually very
purposefully created to serve as a
passport control point between bahrain
and saudi arabia on the king fad
causeway
saudi arabia is home to mecca the
birthplace of the central figure of
islam the prophet muhammad
mecca has a population of about 1.5
million but during the hajj
the yearly pilgrimage to mecca this
triples to almost
5 million people land in mecca is some
of the most expensive in the world at up
to thirteen
thousand dollars per square foot saudi
arabia really isn't great friends with
their southern neighbor
yemen who owns over 200 islands
including saccocha island which is
surprisingly green compared to its
mainland neighbors
and is the only place in the world where
you can find the dragon's blood tree
yemen's national soccer team has played
bhutan three times in the last few
decades
all of which bhutan lost rather horribly
bhutan is home to the genghar puenze
mountain which is believed to be the
tallest unsummoned mountain in the world
since local spiritual beliefs prohibit
anyone from climbing a mountain over 6
000 meters this mountain is in the
himalayas range which if you follow to
the west
brings you to nepal which is of course
home to mount everest the tallest
mountain in the world
everest is 29 029 feet tall
880 times higher than the marshall
islands tallest peak at 33 feet
if you dig a hole straight down through
the earth from the marshall islands you
arrive just off the coast from liberia
which is the country of registration of
11
of the world ships of the 2771
registered ships though
only 190 are actually owned by liberians
foreigners register their ships there
since there are few regulations and low
costs
malta also registers many ships for the
same reason with 1
437 foreign-owned ships malta is a
european union member which means that
we've almost talked about
every eu member our last two are estonia
and ireland
whose northernmost point is actually
farther north than northern ireland
ireland has played samoa six times in
rugby and samoa actually won once
which is quite impressive for a country
of less than two hundred thousand
samoa's rugby team did once lose to new
zealand 101 to 14
though so they're not that good new
zealand has a kind of territory of nue
it's recognized as a freely associated
state meaning by choice
but nue isn't recognized by the un as an
independent country
however nue is exactly on the opposite
side of the world from niger
which is named for the niger river the
niger river has probably the most
bizarre river course in the world
it starts only 150 miles from the
atlantic ocean but then takes a 2 600
mile path to reach the ocean
it starts in sierra leone flows through
guinea mali
niger itself then benin before reaching
the ocean in nigeria
nigeria is also named after the niger
river and is by far
the most populous country in africa at
125 million people
the least populous country in africa is
the seychelles which isn't on the
mainland but is still considered an
african country
they also have what might be the coolest
flag in the world
except for maybe saint lucia's but i do
have to give a solid runner's up
position to st
vincent and the grenadines st vinson and
the grenade's name is rather
purposefully similar to that of its
neighboring island
granada granada's airport wasn't built
until 1985 but nowadays you can fly to
places like port of spain
in trinidad and tobago trinidad is also
the name of a municipality of 20 000
people in honduras
which has two capitals tagusa galpa and
koma yagueya
much like the cote d'ivoire whose
capitals are yamasucro and abajon
despite having a very easy english
translation the ivory coast
the cote d'ivoire is almost always
referred to by this name since its
government refuses to accept any
translated name
if you draw a straight line south from
cote d'ivoire until it crosses
antarctica and goes north you'll end up
intersecting venuatu which is one of
seven countries worldwide
to not be part of the international
criminal police organization
also known as interpol another
non-interpol member country is tuvalu
which is the second smallest country in
the world to have a commercial
international airport
this is also the second video in a row
that i've used this image
watch my last video to find out why
nauru is the smallest country outright
to have an airport
and it rather controversially has camps
for those who attempt to seek asylum in
australia
many of whom are from iraq iraq borders
iran which has 22 ski resorts
that's more than the entire south
american continent
speaking of south america we haven't
covered paraguay which is another one of
these landlocked countries with the navy
and with that we've touched on every
south american country if you dig a hole
through the earth from paraguay you end
up just north of philippines which is
our seventh to last
asian country the other ones are myanmar
which is one of the world's three
countries not using the metric system
timor-leste whose currency is the u.s
dollar despite having no real
connections to the us
pakistan which is home to the third
largest non-polar glacier in the world
despite being at the same latitude of
south texas
jordan which you may think is landlocked
from looking at a map but actually has a
16 mile coast on the red sea
syria which is home to damascus the
oldest continuously inhabited city on
the planet and kuwait
which has the highest value currency in
the world at 3.3 us dollars to each
kuwaiti dinar
with that we've covered every asian
country
one of the lowest value currencies in
the world is the sao tomi and principe
dobra
at twenty three thousand dobra to the
dollar saotomi and principe speaks
portuguese
which means we've covered every
portuguese-speaking country
the country is also off the coast of
cameroon which became the first african
country to reach the fifa world cup
semi-finals in 1990
although that since been accomplished by
ghana where the official and primary
language
is english and there are only three more
countries like this
belize the only english-speaking country
in central america
barbados who has the third highest human
development index score in the western
hemisphere
and antigua and barbuda whose native
language taino
is the origin of english words like
canoe barbecue
hammock and hurricane so we've covered
every english-speaking country but there
are two remaining countries that were
part of the british empire dominica
where antillean creole is the primary
language and mauritius which has the
highest population density in africa at
over 1500 people per square mile
one of the lowest population densities
in africa is in the central african
republic
at 18 people per square mile the central
african republic's northern neighbor
is chad whose embassy in washington dc
is only 200 feet away from that of
burkina faso
whose capital has perhaps the best name
in the world
quakadugu in the southeast of burkina
faso is this piece of togo that is only
connected to the main part by a 300 foot
wide strip of land
this area's roads however all come from
burkina faso which means that much like
point roberts
residents need to cross two
international borders to get to their
own country
there are only three african countries
left comoros
the second largest vanilla producer in
the world burundi the poorest country in
the world to have an olympic medal and
eritrea which has neither an official
or majority spoken language drawing a
latitude line west from eritrea brings
you to nicaragua
home to a lake on an island in a lake
more than one hundred thousand
nicaraguans
live in nearby el salvador which is the
smallest central american country and
the only one
not to have a caribbean coastline el
salvador's northern neighbor is
guatemala whose border with mexico was
originally defined by the course of the
chicksau river but erosion has changed
the course which created a bunch of
enclaves and exclaves like this
this and this and that's our last
country in the western hemisphere we're
getting close
guatemala's embassy in ottawa is about
900 feet away from slovenia's
which has this really messed up border
with croatia including this tiny section
which isn't actually claimed by either
country
making it terra nulas the tenth and
final country to end in
nia and our final country is albania
whose capital is one of the only in
europe to not have a mcdonald's
but wait if you draw a latitude line
from the south of albania that brings
you to the north of afghanistan where
albania sent 44
troops to fight in 2005 and that's where
we started this video so if you're
feeling like a second round
click here to start again i hope you
enjoyed this wendover productions video
i'm very happy to announce that i've
partnered with dftba to bring you
wendover productions t-shirts which look
like this there are two ways to get one
of these you can become a patron
on patreon at the 20 level and receive a
bunch of other great perks like stickers
handwritten letters early access to
videos behind the scenes updates and
more
or you can just purchase the shirt by
itself for the very reasonable cost of
20 dollars
and have it shipped to anywhere in the
world this is the link to order that
shirt or it's also in the description
other than that please be sure to
subscribe to catch every one of my
videos right when it comes out
follow me on twitter at wendoverpro
check out part one of every country in
the world
take a look at my fan moderated
subreddit at reddit.com
r slash wenoverproductions and
contribute to my patreon at
patreon.comwendover
thanks again for watching and i'll see
you next tuesday for another wendover
productions video